[Music]
you know how when you're in a store the
cashier will often ask if you'd like to
be emailed to your receipt
this is a pretty shameless attempt to
secure a really valuable piece of
information your email address it's the
anchor for much of your online identity
and lets brands tally the data they
might have about you with stuff they
might be able to source elsewhere but
crucially it also lets them forge a
direct relationship with you the
customer rather than having to pay for
advertising on a social media platform
on a television screen or a billboard it
can instead send an email straight to
your inbox every week
that lets it promote its latest
offerings give you discounts all without
having to pay for additional ads
the same goes for news organizations
rather than having to fight for an
audience on twitter or facebook every
time a story is published it can instead
send a newsletter with the summary of
the day's news that might be
particularly personal to you the average
american received emails from four news
organizations a week in 2020 and about
the same proportion of people received
their news from email as they do from
mobile notifications
that's why we've seen an explosion in
newsletters and email marketing over the
past few years they let brands evade the
tech gatekeepers and forge direct
relationships with their audience but a
lot of the value resides in knowing
quite how many people are opening those
emails you might have a hundred thousand
subscribers but if you can show that
forty percent of those are opening the
message every week it makes it easier to
attract a sponsor for your newsletter
the same stands for email marketing if
you know how many people are opening the
message you can gauge how effective the
campaign might be
so how do they know you've actually
opened the message well most of these
emails arrive just as blocks of text
with no pictures in order to get the
pictures it will ping a server
download them into the email and in
pinging the server it tells the brand
that you have opened the email as well
as perhaps giving useful information
such as your rough location and what
sort of device you're opening the
message on the unassuming newsletter is
a bit of a trojan horse now as part of a
broader crackdown on advertising
technology apple introduced a tool in
2021 it caused male privacy protection
that system downloads all the images for
your emails irrespective of whether you
open them or not makes it a lot harder
for the sender of the email to know who
has indeed opened their messages and
that's a big deal because about half of
all emails are opened through an apple
app
it's prompted big changes to both the
newsletter and email marketing
industries
rather than being largely subsidized by
advertising newsletters are increasingly
paid subscriber affairs the new york
times has taken many of its top
newsletters behind the paywall meaning
that it only goes to people paying for a
subscription and email marketers are
working harder to get you to click
through their content to an outside
website if you've clicked on it that
means you've opened the message
it's made apple into a gatekeeper of
your inbox long the preserve of google
its gmail service has for a long time
filtered your emails into primary social
and promotional inboxes those last two
are sort of a purgatory between the
heaven of your normal inbox and the hell
of your spam folder and don't get as
many eyeballs
in the data wars even your inbox is a
fierce battleground
[Music]